[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lavelle
a lot of questions what does it mean to
be a conservative today
is donald trump a conservative and did
he change what it means to be a
conservative
what about the issue of class and
finally what does it take for
conservatives
to win
[Music]
to crosstalk these issues and more i'm
joined by my guest
hannah cox in greenville she is a news
max insider
as well as contributor to the washington
examiner and in toronto we have arthur
clero he is editor at large
at being libertarian dot com all right
crosstalk rules in effect that means you
can jump in anytime you want and i
always appreciate it
okay let's go to hana in greenville um
in my introduction i asked
the question what does it mean to be a
conservative today in your mind what
does it mean to be a conservative and
let's keep in mind
uh the trump presidency and the recent
general election go ahead
well in my mind it means to be a concern
of what it's always meant which is that
we are working to conserve the classical
liberal values our country was founded
upon
but i think there's a real fracture
within conservatism these days i think
trump has uh
increased that fracture i think it was
existing before he actually came into
office but it has
become deeper and more visible and i
think that there are a lot of
conservatives who want to move
that uh movement into the direction that
he was mostly focusing on which has a
lot more nationalism involved
and isn't always as attached to our
classical liberal foundings as i would
like to see the movement attached to so
um i think it'll be interesting to see
where conservatism goes in the next
couple of years i don't think there's a
solid answer for where it ends up right
now there's there's sort of a battle to
be fought
um well so let me taking away from what
you just said there you
i guess i can read that into that is
that trump did not have a positive
impact on conservativism
during his time in office well i guess
it depends on the perspective you're
looking at it from from my opinion no as
someone who is really concerned with
free market values with individual
liberty with limiting the government
i didn't see a lot of that in the trump
presidency that being said
i do think for people who are more
concerned with issues surrounding the
culture war
surrounding um the popularity of the
movement surrounding
attracting a more diverse population to
the movement
i think there were some positive
takeaways that you could credit to him
and i think that those are interesting
and that's why i think i i say there's a
battle to be fought because there's a
lot of new blood that he brought into
conservatism
there's a lot of people who've been
pushed out because of him and
conservativism
and so if those people uh come back if
if those new people stay
if there's gonna kind of be a turf war
because i don't think they're fighting
for the same
ideology largely oh i don't think they
are on that point you and i will
definitely agree here
the same question to you i mean how has
trump
changed conservatives in america if at
all and if it is it good or is it for
the worse go ahead so i do think that he
definitely changed conservatism in
america um
i think that up until trump
you had a sort of conservative
definitely since uh bush won in bush two
you had a certain conservatism that was
very focused on
uh global expansion is very focused on
what i guess would be term
neoconservatism
um and even from from bush to obama to
to trump you have the american people
voting for someone who's gonna
stop global expansion stop this kind of
focus on the
exterior and focus more at home rebuild
infrastructure you know
focus on programs at home so i think
that he kind of gave the people what
they wanted
he gave a lot of the tea partiers
particularly and conservatives what they
wanted what they're looking for
i am a conservative president
i think even further though he he kind
of reinspired
to to kind of talk to what hannah was
saying there with the nationalism i
think he
did reinspire a nationalist in the
united states which was kind of waning
there was a progressive push to kind of
put nationalism the same place as racism
or some of these other things
as something evil or something that you
shouldn't be doing this we're in a
global world now
nations are a thing of the past and i
think that
that every country has kind of
recognized there's there's um
there's a balance there to be had yeah i
think trump kind of brought us back into
that balance
okay well that's it's kind of
interesting i mean i mean because
you know with great power politics it's
every country
you know thinks of themselves first okay
and i would tend to agree with you is
that um
you know when you look at look at trade
deals since the end of the second world
war
well that was to bring people into the
western alliance and the united states
picked up the slack well
you do that for you know five six seven
decades
it ends up being quite costly okay and
the working class and i want to talk
about that later in the program they're
the ones that were acutely aware of it
most and that's why they voted for him
and voted for him twice
okay and i mean it when i look
when i look at conservativism you know
there's obviously a very
at least since uh ronald reagan a very
strong libertarian
element within conservativism it's
called fusion um which i have my
very strong doubts about um but it seems
to me that
in the way a lot of traditional
conservatives they're
they're basically willing to fight the
culture wars okay
and not really look at um because you
know looking at reagan economics i i i
don't think it worked it didn't work for
the
vast majority of people for reasons that
arthur just said here i mean
ends up globalism exports your jobs
okay and and the working working people
revolted against that so is it really
just about culture wars because that's
what really gets all the news all the
time is you know how you fall on the
culture wars
which you know that gets everyone's
blood up and you know the blue
checks get really excited but it doesn't
really change
the condition of the vast majority of
the people that identify as being
conservative
and their material existence go ahead
honey
well i think that's a really great
question and i think at the end of the
day we should be focusing on the
economics because that is what people
vote on that is why we saw so many
working class people vote for him
i happen to think he's dead wrong on the
economics though i don't think that the
reason we've seen jobs leave this
country
have as much to do with trade deals or
have as much to do
with um many of the other things that we
saw him point towards immigration and
other things of that nature
rather i think they had a lot more to do
with our actual economic policies here
in this country which are pretty
atrocious we have
for many many years been making it a
terrible business climate we've been
raising our corporate tax rates
we've been over regulating many many
industries we have been pushing
companies out because we've made it too
expensive to do business here and that
is what needs to be targeted we actually
see
that many of the european uh countries
are often pointed to
as socialist countries have better free
market economies than we do and actually
rank higher than us
on the freedom index scale and i think
that that is because if you look at what
they did starting in the 1990s they
reversed course they moved back from
some of their socialist policies they
started
removing regulations they started
increasing trade they started
making it easier to get a job and to
work and to make good pay
that's what our focus should be on and i
think that trump's policies while well
intended have missed the mark in that
regard and i think had we seen another
four years of trump
sans coronavirus and some of the
economic institution that that amplified
we would have started to felt some of
the effects of those policies that he
was pushing around his trade
well arthur well when it's defined that
way i don't see a big difference between
republicans and democrats
whatsoever
i don't really see that where the free
market is i mean i mean
both parties and and trump never really
challenged corporate america
as a matter of fact much to my chagrin
every time he said
well look at the high stock market i
mean what does that have to do with the
average person it doesn't
at all and it's almost kind of insulting
you know because oh well your your rich
friends are doing really well wonderful
okay
but what about us okay and and i think
that it has less to do with free markets
and regulation
then basically i mean the the the first
um stimulus package that went through i
mean
you checked off all your the richest
people in the world got checked out
first with concierge service okay that
has nothing to do with free trade
not at all okay it means you're too big
to fail
go ahead i think that's been an issue
for a long time i think actually i think
a lot of the issues that that face
america and kind of the western world
come down to that
you have governments now that answer
more to
special interests or globalist
organizations than they do to their own
publics
and kind of the voting public is more of
a yeah if we can whip them up to
to support us that's our stamp of
approval technically
but when you look at the policy very
little of it is actually oh yeah you
know this would actually benefit a huge
number of people it's really more this
will make me look good or this is
for my special interests and i think
that's where
we get to the root of the problem and
the root of the trump phenomena
which was the idea that this guy is not
someone who's been there for 40 years or
for 60 years or whatever it is who is
bought out
and you know completely uh what's the
word
he owes his his entire career to someone
else this is someone who potentially
could actually just enact policy that
does good for us
and i think even on the on the free
trade part um
you know i'm not an economics expert but
though from what i do know yeah you do
want free trade you don't want free
markets sure
absolutely yeah but i i want it too but
it it's over what we have is too much
monopoly control
okay and no one wants to challenge that
no one wants to challenge that
as a matter of fact they're given
protections i mean look at the tech
companies they're given amazing
cutouts that has nothing to do that is
actually anti-free market
go ahead absolutely and i think i think
this is the the point that more
libertarians and conservatives really
need to focus on
because it's it's a case where you do
have a socialism
for a kind of certain class of people or
certain group of people that
are too big to fail and the government
regulations and
it is government involvement it's this
unholy alliance between corporatism and
government
that is and this is where actually
what's interesting is
i think in some ways the left got this
right
with their complaint of the one percent
but then they've kind of gone too far
with it
and in some ways the right has gotten
this wrong with their with
kind of throwing this unholy alliance of
government and corporate
into the idea of it's a free market
which it's not and
it's the opposite like you said i 100
agree with that
yeah i just want to say i agree with
everything he said and i and i
absolutely think
that the primary focus for us as people
on the right as as conservatives as
libertarians needs to be on cronyism
because it is an abundance and we have
so many people in this country that are
mad at the ramifications of cronyism so
they're demanding a new system right
they blame capitalism because they think
that this is how capitalism functions
when really this is how government
functions when it gets involved in the
market
and starts giving special favors and
special deals to their buddies and it's
wrong
it's not free markets it is cronyism
it's corrupt and it hurts people
and i think that that's something that
we should be able to form really big
broad coalitions on even including
people on the left because if you can
help them understand why the things that
they dislike
by that this is exactly what i've been
proposing for a long time here
i mean they think they you know when the
the first stimulus you know all of the
all the super rich were taken care of
even if they didn't even need the money
wasn't that an echo of 2008 again that
really angered me
and then you tell tens of millions of
people that you can't
work you can't work you have to stay
home
all the politicians are being paid they
work from their office you know
and and that's when and and this where
people on the right disagree with me
that's when
you need to use the power of the state
because if you tell people they can't
work
then you have to at least make an
attempt to help them
okay to get through uh uh this tough um
uh
a patch that we're going through because
everyone else is doing fine
it's a this is what really irritates a
lot of people
and we'll i guess we'll find out how
much of an impact that had on this
election because
i'll tell you personally i have no idea
what happened in this past election and
i don't know if we're gonna know
what happened for a very long time but
these these are
you know we're rapidly running out of
time for the first part of the program
but i want to in the second part of the
program i want to talk about
the issue of class and how this plays
into conservativism because i think this
is an
open lane that i think the conservatives
have to think about more seriously
and and we have to worry about all of
the money that's in politics because
you know if we take if we start looking
at the needs of the working class they
will
vote republican and we know that for a
fact because
um the working class did support trump
at least that's what
we're told here i'm going to jump in
here we're going to short break and
after that short break we'll continue
our discussion on conservatism stay with
[Music]
rt
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter level to
remind you we're talking about what it
means to be a conservative today
okay let's go back to hannah hannah in
the election results that we've been
given
number one trump uh um got over 10
million more votes and
when you look at the the people that
voted for him it's it surprised
a lot of the uh left-wing pundits they
probably won't admit it but
um more blacks uh more brown people
um even women um uh voted for donald
trump and a lot of these people come
from the working class
is this an opportunity for republicans
specifically to
make a more appealing case for working
people because
the democrats are the party of big tech
of media of hollywood
and um the very very poor i mean they
make sure that they have a voting base
that are
that look for dependency on the
government but working people just want
to work
okay and is this an opportunity for the
republicans to kind of rethink their
the way they approach the electorate
yeah absolutely peter and i think that
we're seeing a real shift in the parties
right now in this country and have been
seeing that shift since about 2012 and
you know in the party shift we'll look
back in
two decades and say oh this is what was
happening then when you're in the midst
of it it can
kind of feel crazy um but what we're
seeing is we are seeing
a large amount of people disinterested
with the democrat party right like
they've been making their case
they built the party they currently have
in the 1960s so they've been out here
with these policies and these ideas and
with the same base for you know
four or five decades and people are fed
up they they're kind of hitting this
point where they're saying you know what
you guys actually never come through
you keep saying you're for the working
class you keep saying you're for us you
keep saying you're gonna improve these
things and you don't actually
do it um and so there's a i think
there's a real openness to look at other
ideas and and to move directions and
and i think to some extent you see that
on the right as well just not as
in large numbers so i think we're going
to continue seeing some migration
between both parties but i certainly
think there's a case to be made within
republicanism for why these ideas
work for everybody and they do right if
we really get it right if we really get
down to
true free market capitalism if we get
the government out of the way if we
actually let people
work then really cool things can happen
we've seen them happen in our country
before we've seen amazing wealth
creation
innovation we've seen great progress
we've seen quality of life increase and
and so i think that
the door's wide open and i'm excited to
see who steps through it what kind of
leaders might emerge from this
i'm curious to see specifically you know
as somebody who's more on the
libertarian end of the conservative
movement i'd like to see some people
like rand paul continue to gain
prominence and make this case and
and i think that um they'll find there's
real you know feudal soul soil to do
that in and that we could really uh
create a new coalition
what about josh hawley i hate josh
hawley with every fiber
would say that okay but yeah nothing
makes me mad
holly but i think that josh hawley is a
a very prominent uh prospect for the
republican party because i think he's
willing to look reshuffle the deck and
look at things afresh
i'm just putting that out there because
i actually have a lot of admiration for
josh hawley and bernie sanders
to the the two senators and then the 98
cowards that just
just didn't want to do anything and i
think it's just absolutely shameful
and i appreciate what josh did and
bernie sanders okay but to be honest
with you
arthur what do you think about that
because with you logic would kind of
dictate you know
when you look at the blue states that's
where the working class are clobbered
the most
but they vote blue i mean isn't this an
opportunity to kind of
you know go into that lane that no one
is in and just say and i mean
if i would have been trump during the
campaign because i thought he ran an
awful campaign
awful and so did the biden people that
the american people deserve much better
okay
but if i had been donald trump i would
have taken the bowie pulpit and just
said
i will keep you whole and
if the republicans aren't behind me then
i won't support you in this campaign
because when you look at the campaign
coming up in georgia
every single conservative should be
terrified you know why because people
voted for trump
they didn't vote for republicans they
okay and and they and you know the the
people around trump
a lot of them libertarian excuse me
hannah um gave him very bad advice
during that time what libertarian hang
on hang on during a time
when he needed to be an fdr and he
didn't do it go ahead arthur
i think there's two points to this i
think the first point is
on the one hand trump seemed almost
torn like he had his instincts that had
he gone with them i think he would have
been
ten times better than he did done ten
times better than he did but
i think he's been torn by whatever i
don't know if it's advice i'm not part
of his inner circle obviously
but for some reason he seemed to be
second guessing and that was on corona
that was on um different policies
there's a lot of stuff this last
year and a half or so leading up to the
election that
seemed like it wasn't trump and on the
on the other hand
i think the one thing that trump did um
to be honest i don't think the
republican party would have won another
election at least not for a long long
time
had it not been for trump i think that
he
kind of brought in something that was
even more than just the economics the
economics is important i mean everyone
needs to pay their bills
but he brought in some like almost uh a
feeling of the
past and i mean this in a good way
where it was like you know what we can
belong to something we can belong to
this country
and this is a great country and it's
it's okay to love it it's okay to love
the constitution and the the values and
the principles it's found on it's okay
to love
these things and it's okay and and
everyone here if you're here in this
country and you you're american you
belong to this
and we can rally around that and i think
that that inspired a lot of people and
that's why you have these these election
results that are better than
romney or mccain or you know any of
these guys that came before and i think
had the republican party
gone the way that they were going with
romney and mccain i think it would have
just been it died
just another dad 2016 2020 and and i
mean you know
you know no matter what happens i mean
the republican party is always going to
be jeb bush okay
and if and if you if you push against it
like trump did
they are going to abandon you with some
notable exceptions and media the
republican party did not back donald
trump
it was the base that did it in spite of
the party leadership
and i find and and i find it very very
frustrating
because it's one of these weird things
hannah one of these real
weird things is because uh
the republican party is popular
because of donald trump not because of
the other luminaries in the party at all
they're not particularly popular
um and for very good reason i mean
they're not charismatic uh they they uh
we uh
tax cut do you like deregulate done our
work is done we're going home that's all
they say
and that doesn't resonate with working
people they say well what about us
you know just as you know healthcare for
all is popular very popular with trump
supporters
though the the republican leadership
doesn't want to recognize that but it's
an absolute fact
go ahead well it's just because it's
popular doesn't mean we do it
socialism's popular and i don't want to
try that out like that's not a case
you know you want to stop the
conversation okay if you say single
payer
okay these scare tactics i think people
are tired of
and a lot of scared republican a lot of
republican supporters a lot of trump
supporters
don't say that they say we'd like some
more health care can you help they do
they do and so go vote for the democrats
because they've been offering that free
piggy bank of taxpayer dollars forever
and
what have they got obamacare another
corporate deal
another corporate thing okay and that's
all any of it will ever be because
let's be serious while people give
different talking points
behind the scenes both of these parties
operate in virtually the exact same
manner
they're always enriching themselves
they're always enriching their buddies
and any massive piece of legislation you
get through congress is going to look
like that until you get serious and fix
the money in politics so
that's that's just kind of besides the
point that doesn't really matter and
whether or not something's
popular you're saying you're not saying
is that
it's a broken politics is that you can't
do anything about it and
that is no you can but we're focusing on
the wrong things
and you can do something about it but
that's not what we're fighting about
we're largely fighting about these
the systemic symptoms of the problem two
years
two years all of the government was his
everything okay and what did they do
they didn't even do
infrastructure okay they did a tax cut
do you know trump's presidency was at
his lowest point
his popularity was at its lowest point
when they pass the tax
cut now that's good for rich people okay
fine okay i don't begrudge them
but it didn't it didn't impact the the
working-class um voters okay and so
and then if you look if you look and now
i'll go to um
arthur here is that when was trump most
popular
among republicans right during the
impeachment
okay when he was being impeached he was
the most popular he had the highest
point there okay
what i'm trying to get at is that if if
trump had been much more imaginative
in using his popularity and his
coattails he could have gotten something
but he he didn't push a health care
reform which he said he would during the
campaign
and he didn't do anything about
infrastructure which i think would have
been
the most important legacy of his
presidency and it'll it
it's a footnote now go ahead i think i
think one of the things to keep in mind
too
is if you if this is the thing when you
vote in an outsider is
everything's uphill right this is a big
club as as hannah was saying government
especially united states but everywhere
in the western world it's a big club and
if you're an outsider you're not one of
the boys
and so it's it's going to be a struggle
to get anything done
especially if you're trying to do
anything that's different that's gonna
you know buck the tide a little bit but
i think to to the point you were saying
earlier into what hannah was saying as
well
i think for conservatives particularly
um
and libertarians and anyone who kind of
loves freedom i think it's time now to
to take
the old talking points and the old kind
of ways of doing things
maybe not toss them out but maybe
reimagine them because even let's
take healthcare for example i'm canadian
i i have canadian health care and you
know
to be very frank it is nice to not worry
about
my you know paying my bill i i have i
have health care too
i don't you think about health care do
you think about it
i really don't but there there's a
there's a downside to this
that we kind of found out during this
virus where when the government owns
your health care
all of a sudden the government gets to
dictate things to you and you don't have
that choice
now sadly the u.s doesn't have a whole
lot of choice either
they just kind of have a bad mix of both
right
but when you have those options when you
have
you know maybe there's some sort of
protected insurance that can be put out
there that's made so that
i don't know i'm not going to pretend to
come up with a policy right now
you said a word
or you said let's try to reimagine it i
think that's the best place to start
but that's the best place to start and
and and take you know the
these assumptions that have been you
know carved into stone and re rethink
them here we're rapidly running out of
time hannah
um would you i suppose you do not want
to see donald trump run again in
2024 i don't but i do agree with arthur
i think that we need to come up with
better solutions i think the reason you
see people asking for single-payer
healthcare is because nobody said
here's an alternate that's better and
that could work better than that and
that needs to happen i have a really big
bone to pick with people on the right
who constantly say no no no no no to
suggestions of policies on the left and
then never come up with their own ideas
that's quite frustrating
we do need to see people step into that
but i will leave you with this donald
trump
lost most of the swing states by a
margin that was less than the number of
libertarian votes in that state
so had he done more to reach out to
libertarian voters like myself you could
be seeing him as president right now
that is the first time i've heard that
and that's absolutely fascinating
uh i'm still trying to figure out what
actually happened in the election but
um uh uh but i have no doubt that we'll
be looking forward to a biden
administration okay that's all the time
we have here i want to thank
my guests in greenville and toronto and
i want to thank our viewers for watching
us here at rt see you next time and
remember
crosstalk rules